en 2016 lorsque claude guéant est
condamné pour avoir détourné deux cent
seize mille euros ce dernier ne se prend
que 75000 euros d'amendé et deux ans
avec sursis alors qu'en théorie le
détournement de fonds et la complicité
sont punissables de dix ans de prison et
150 mille euros d'amendé
par contre un sdf qui volent 17 euros 20
nourriture en mai de la même année il
prend lui deux mois de prison ferme
ça reste lui à une question se pose donc
nécessairement aujourd'hui en france 227
entre la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen serait-il
malheureusement possible que certains
citoyens soient plus égaux que d'autres
alors je vous vois déjà arrivé à et
votre air députés derrière votre écran
tu nous apprends rien ils sont tous
pourris range une fourche éteignons nos
torche
car il convient de remettre certaines
choses dans leur contexte déjà la frange
abusive et restent minoritaires
chaque jour il ya des millions de
personnes appartenant au système que
l'on adore décrié qui se lèvent tôt pour
que tout continue de fonctionner
correctement en france c'est d'autant
plus admirable que ces derniers sont
parfois au plus près des abus perpétrés
par d'autres ce qui n'est jamais très
bon pour la motivation pour cet épisode
nous nous concentrons uniquement sur les
parlementaires pour ceux qui ne seraient
pas ce que le terme recouvre ça recouvre
les députés et les sénateurs
pourquoi eux pas parce que sa vie des
gens qui proposent et votent les lois
ainsi se retrouve trop avantagés par
l'état comment ils peuvent voter des
lois pour améliorer le quotidien des
simples citoyens que nous sommes
puisque finalement le quotidien ils ne
connaissent pas déjà quand on essaie
simplement de faire un point sur les
avantages inhérents à leurs fonctions on
tombe sur un hic il existe des
inégalités de traitement entre un
parlementaire qui travaillent dans le
public est un citoyen lambda
l'un d'eux était basique mensuel d'un
sénateur ou d'un député elle est de 5000
514 euros brut
l'idée ce n'est pas de créer une
polémique autour du montant du salaire
d'un parlementaire ainsi un montant qui
est naturellement élevé car elle a pour
but initial de stopper toute volonté
d'accepter des à côtés et donc de
freiner toute forme de corruption
mais cette indemnité de base elle est
complétée par une indemnité de résidence
de 165 euros et par une indemnité de
fonction de 1420 euros bruts par le
montant peut commencer à paraître élevé
mais n'oublions pas que ces derniers
paient aussi des impôts et qu'ils
occupent parmi les plus hauts postes de
l'état français basculer en est le
salaire n'est d'ailleurs plus que de
5000 379 euros par mois ce qui est
globalement le salaire mensuel net d'un
cadre par exemple là où les vraies
inégalités commencent c'est que
l'indemnité de fonction dont je parlais
juste avant
elle est non imposable et que le salaire
est aussi complété par l'ifm
et non ce n'est pas une radio et il
s'agit de l'indemnité représentative des
prés de landas genre de note de frais et
elle est elle aussi non imposables elle
aussi entre 5779 et 6037 oro est en fait
c'est devenu un complément de salaire
car si le but initial de l'irfm était
d'assumer les frais professionnels
inhérents à la fonction de parlementaire
elle est trop souvent utilisée comme
complément à l'air puisque elle n'est
pas contrôlée et ne nécessite aucun
justificatif ce que personnellement je
trouve absolument fou 1 aucun contrôle
0e justificatives à fournir combien de
fois dans l'histoire de l'entreprise
il a été impossible un salarié de se
faire rembourser en notes de frais un
ticket de métro 1 euros 90 qu'il avait
perdu la faute de contrôles aléatoires
ou d'une simple vérification de
justificatifs cahuzac par exemple
utiliser son rfm dans un magasin de
hammam et piscine et s'il m'écoute je
lui déconseille d'aller se baigner
c'est beaucoup trop dangereux pour un
homme qui dérivent autant à tout cela
s'ajoute une cinquième round up qui
varient entre 7500 48 euros et 9500 4
euros brut sous forme de crédits que les
parlementaires ne peuvent utiliser
uniquement pour rémunérer leurs
collaborateurs peu d'arnèke dessus par
un mec si puisqu'il est possible en fait
d'euros versés sans explication 50 % de
cette troisième enveloppe dans son nid
rfm et rfm qui pour rappel et dilapide
abl sans aucun contrôle et qui n'est pas
imposable
donc niveau fils de rit on est à 8
sur 10 sur l'échelle de balkany c'est
plutôt balèze alors ok les
parlementaires sont logiquement bien
payé ce qui est moins normal en revanche
c'est qu'une partie de ce qu'ils
touchent soit non imposables un partie
plus ou moins importante en fonction de
l'honnêteté l'individu et donc de la
part-dieu fm qu'il attribue à ses dépens
ce perso dans plus grande est calme ceux
qui abusent le plus peuvent bénéficier
d'un bonus de plus de 50 % de salaire
non imposable et c'est un premier
problème que cela leur donne un statut
différent de celui du contribuable qui
voit ses impôts augmenter inexorablement
année après année et reste imposable sur
la totalité de son salaire
après l'argent ne fait pas tout dans un
statut on peut aussi parler du chômage
deux cas de figure le premier le
parlementaire est issu de la fonction
publique en cas des fêtes et de perdre
de son mandat il retrouvera directement
son ancien poste 1
le mec sont le chômage et passe
directement au dessert c'est vrai que
c'est pratique second cas de figure pour
les parlementaires issus du privé
surprise générale leur chômage et moins
enjeu que le régime général true story
enfin moins avantageux d'un point de vue
pécuniaire uniquement puisqu'ils ont
l'avantagé d'avoir droit à des
indemnités même lorsqu'ils sont
démissionnaires
mais même si leur chômage est
globalement moins avantageux que le
régime général
il n'a concerné que onze députés sur 577
en 2012 autant vous dire personne le
chômage n'est donc une préoccupation des
parlementaires que lorsqu'ils touchent
les autres et puisqu'on parle des sujets
qui fâchent parlant du système de
retraite des parlementaires suffisamment
avantageux pour faire passer les
avantages du cheminots syndiqués dont on
nous parle à longueur d'année pour une
personne déjà engagé socialement parce
que bon jusqu'en novembre 2010 avec les
opacités des salaires dont on a parlé
plus tôt les députés pouvaient payer
leur cotisation plus vite cela
permettait donc aux parlementaires de
cotiser 22 ans et demi pour une retraite
complète contre plus de 40 ans
aujourd'hui pour un salarié
cela permettait aussi à un député de
toucher une allocation vieillesse de
1500 euros net pour 5 ans de mandat et
de 6000 euros après 20 ans de mandat
donc ça c'était donc avant on appelait
ça la double peine la double la double
cotisation
heureusement depuis novembre 2010 cette
odieuse pratique arrêtait pourfendu on
ou presque parce que si on parle d'une
baisse de la tension post réforme de
près de 30%
ils ont toujours accès à un régime
particulier et si on fait les comptes
un député est encore assuré de toucher
près de monde 200 euros de pension après
un premier mandat de cinq ans soit un
montant quasi équivalent à celui de la
pension médiane touchés par les français
environ 1300 euros après une carrière
complète c'est fou surtout quand on sait
que les cotisations des députés ne
couvre que 2% de la totalité des
prestations versées par leur caisse de
retraite
je vous laisse imaginer qui paie le
reste si l'on cumule avec un fort
problèmes d'absentéisme qui lui vaut
plus un n'est pas très contrôlés et
encore moins sanctionnés quand il est
des parlementaires comme par exemple
françois vendasi ancien sénateur de la
haute corse peuvent toucher une retraite
conséquente pour un jour de travail au
sénat par an soit une retraite monstre
pour neuf jours de boulot sur la
totalité de ses mandats plutôt rentable
et plutôt injuste est donc difficile de
considérer que les gens qui voient
qu'elle loue en france aujourd'hui soit
égalité avec les citoyens qui les
subissent et forcément on perd confiance
dans ses institutions lorsque l'on sait
tout ce que j'ai à vous dire
mais le vrai problème ce n'est pas
uniquement les inégalités légal et
parfois franchement immoral dans le
statut de parlementaire et sud citoyens
mais les abus que ce système engendre
car lorsqu'une personne se pensent
supérieur
reste de la population quelques toits et
minorité d'autres gens qui partagent son
opinion est que ces gens ont la
possibilité de voter modifier ou bloquer
des lois à 4 dans l'assemblée en pleine
nuit
qu'est ce qui les empêche d'en profiter
même quand des députés tentent de
limiter les abus d'autres les contre ont
fait deux pas en avant un seul pas en
arrière
par exemple depuis peu les députés
doivent déclarer leur patrimoine sans en
omettre la moindre virgule un texte de
loi est apparue en 2010 avant sans qu'un
élu tricheurs pouvait être condamné à
une lourde amende de la prison ferme et
une inéligibilité éventuelle
et bien christian jacob et jean-françois
copé ont voulu la même année déposé un
amendement s'opposant à la création
d'une incrimination pénale spécifique
pour les députés faisant de fausses
déclarations comme ça posément ils ont
essayé de nous couper l'herbe sous le
pied si je puis dire
alors heureusement les conséquences sont
pas fait attendre un levée de boucliers
à gauche et à droite ça sent qu
rassurant cela dit ils ont quand même
réussi à faire discrètement sauter la
peine de prison prévues par la loi
initial du coup encore aujourd'hui un
élu qui a fait une évaluation
volontairement mensongère de patrimoine
visant à camoufler une partie cahuzac
style pourra juste être puni de trente
mille euros d'amande et là on se
rappelle du sdf qui prend deux mois pour
10 7 euros 22 vols et bah ça pique et
finalement c'est un problème plutôt
symptomatique des dérives des
parlementaires tous ne sont pas pourris
mais persiste une certaine complaisance
envers les pourris qui ne peut
qu'encourager les citoyens que nous
sommes à perdre confiance en la
politique
un bon exemple reste celui des retraites
des anciens présidents qui nous coûte
pour rappel près de 10 millions d'euros
par an exactement 10 points 3 millions
le tout ne représente sur aucune base
juridique puisque cela découle d'une
décision 1 signé en 1985 par laurent
fabius alors premier ministre de
françois mitterrand est ce qui rend fou
c'est que personne n'a tenté de faire
quoi que ce soit avant la tentative
timide de françois hollande d'organiser
une étude pour voir si en france on
offrait pas trop davantage à nos ex
président pour ne finalement mettre en
place qu'une timide dégressivité des
avantages
et pourtant de nombreuses solutions
existent et chacun a son rôle à jouer
parce que bon au moins chez moi ça sent
le pourri j'ouvre la fenêtre jaer voilà
c'est pareil il ya deux idées
actuellement à l'étude qui pourrait
permettre un nettoyage drastique des
pourris qui s'accrochent comme une belle
plaques d'humidité sur les murs de nos
institutions parlementaires
la première se serait d'exiger d'avoir
un casier vierge pour pouvoir être
parlementaire parce qu'en france
enfin le casier vierge pour exercer 396
métier mais pas pour être parlementaire
et ça ça craint
un élu récidivistes ne devraient pas
avoir le droit de se représenter je
doute que les trois ans de prison et
cinq ans d'inéligibilité concours
cahuzac l'empêchent de revenir en
politique
mettre en place cette mesure simple
tranchera définitivement le débat sur
l'inéligibilité et les durées à
appliquer en fonction de la
transgression en une façon d'ouvrir la
fenêtre pour faire entrer un peu d'air
frais une seconde manière des
partenaires ce serait d'entamer un vrai
débat sur le non cumul des mandats on
parle souvent de non cumul des mandats
tout court un parlementaire ne devrait
être que député ou sénateur et pas
député et maire par exemple parce que ça
nous prendrait trop de temps on peut pas
être concentré sur les deux fonctions à
fond sa demande du dévouement et en plus
on peut y avoir des conflits d'intérêts
espérons que 2010 est verra la fin de
cette pratique et des conséquences
néfastes qu'elle encourage ceux aux tons
parlement par contre c'est le non cumul
dans le temps qui encourage des
parlementaires à devenir des politiques
de carrière l'occupation de
parlementaires elle ne devrait pas être
un métier mais un engagement temporaire
et s'est même pas moi qui le dit c'est
le député laurent grandguillaume députés
ps qui a décidé de ne pas se représenter
après 2017 car il considère avoir fait
ce qu'il avait à faire
après dix ans de mandat l'intérêt cette
mesure va mettre en place une date de
péremption sur la fonction de
parlementaire ce qui pourrait accélérer
la circulation des parlementaires au
sein des assemblées permettant de
rééquilibrer la provenance de ces
derniers entre privé et public et
favoriser la diversité et la mixité qui
font toujours cruellement défaut chez
les parlementaires tous d'accord avec
vous sa plus grave mais élections
pétition partage d'informations à vous
de choisir votre façon de procéder pour
ouvrir la fenêtre
tant que c'est pas pour sauter merci à
tous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
j'espère qu'elle vous a plu j'espère que
vous avez appris des choses n'hésitez
pas à la partager
si ça vous semble utile merci à tous
ceux qui soutiennent le projet sur tipi
à un gros pouce en l'air vous êtes top
soutenir le projet comme ça c'est
vachement plaisir
merci beaucoup je dit pas assez mais
merci aussi à tous ceux qui commentent
qui partagent qu'il avec les vidéos
c'est difficile de répondre
enfin même je réponds très rarement sur
youtube parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
commentaires mais voilà sachez que je
les lis et que ça me fait vachement
plaisir à chaque fois on se retrouve
normalement dimanche pour t'imagines si
normalement si tout va bien quand je
fais cette vidéo je crois que tout va
bien se passer
mais les succès se passe pas bien donc
voilà ma maman dimanche t'imagines si on
se retrouve aussi la semaine prochaine
même jour pour un autre épisode d'un
autre format
on va se poser une question un peu
différente de d'habitude love peace
élections
c'est une bande tournage madame s